hi i'm mel graham from the university of
minnesota and i'm delighted to be
presenting today thanks to the
invitation from
njabr and the north american 3rs
collaborative
some of our work coming out of the
pre-clinical research center
so today i'm going to talk through some
of the the objectives that we hope to
with the laboratory animal sciences
programs to talk a little bit about the
role of how we design our experiments
and the way we select our models and how
that influences animal welfare and how
it
actually impacts our scientific outcomes
in a major way
and how those two are intertwined i'm
going to talk through some example
strategies using behavioral management
to intentionally introduce variation for
generalizability of these translational
programs
or reduce from the confounding to make
our experiments more robust
so my research really is focusing on
metabolic disease
and immunology and transplantation and
particularly diabetes and i always like
to describe why this is important right
because when we talk about using animals
and particularly when we talk about
using primates the focus of this talk
we really want to understand what the
relation to benefit is
so when we think about diabetes in
particular type 1 diabetes
what we recognize is this is a serious
disease insulin isn't a cure for
diabetes
it just keeps our patients alive until
we find one
this disease is remarkably prevalent 422
million adults have diabetes
and that is rising and along with that
comes a lot of complications that we see
for these patients
ranging from stroke to cardiovascular
disease to
kidney disease and this is highly
expensive to the u.s healthcare system
we have 30 million americans
that are are being treated annually at a
cost of uh
327 billion dollars per year
so when we think about what kind of
models that we we're targeting to really
move some of the work that we're we're
looking at in discovery basis
into our clinical therapeutics that
benefits our patients
we start looking at the at the beginning
we look at our in vitro models and
silicon
models to to screen and as we walk
towards our large animal models towards
translation we anticipate that that
translational relevance increases
but that spectrum is is blurring as we
see and you'll see certainly from other
speakers in this conference that really
what drives the model is less about sort
of the spectrum that we're all so used
to
but really looking at different aspects
of validity that drive the selection of
these models the first being face
validity so does the model itself have
similar physiology
in the case of diabetes we often think
about things like hyperglycemia or
glucose intolerance
is the construct validity accurate so is
there
similar underlying biology or etiology
of disease so for example in type 1
diabetes we're looking at beta cell loss
and this is something to think about as
you're looking at the model because when
we talk about if we're looking at beta
cell loss from the prevention
perspective
the chemical surgical induction of
diabetes violates that autoimmune
construct that we typically see in our
small animal models
and sort of the holy grail when we think
about selecting models is really
predictive validity so does the model
have a similar response to clinically
effective interventions or therapeutic
agents
and i'm going to use immunosuppression
as a good example of this
and i wanted to also highlight some some
sort of ways in which we
think about how these different areas so
for example facing construct validity
can really tackle some of the problems
that we see
and one of the things that's that's
relevant at least in diabetes is we know
that
differences exist in insulin sensitivity
and fat depot is between females and
males
so you'll see that there's metabolic
control differences in males versus
females under equivalent treatment so
again we have to look to
what's our experimental outcome that
we're interested in and look at that
again
similar physiology or underlying biology
as we select that model
also as we think about what our animal
models can do for us as we think towards
translation
is we can look at what's happening on
the clinical side where we see things
like underrepresentation of males and
clinical
obesity evaluations despite knowing that
obesity is prevalent
equivalently between sexes so this is a
way that we can balance in our animal
cohorts in the design
phase to really unravel some of those
sex-driven treatment outcome effects
so why do we really look at primates you
know why is that a focus of one of the
lectures here today
and i think again what we talked about
is at least uh
conventionally in vitro and rodent
studies support pathway determination or
our mechanistic studies that's really
where we
we lean heavily on those two modalities
where nhps
we get into examining practicality
safety and generalized advocacy
and what we know is that there's this
high relevance to the clinic and why is
that because of our close genetic
relationship and you see of course on
that image to the side
that you know again you're sort of
looking at how divergent you are
along the evolutionary spectrum and
because of that close genetic
relationship
we have remarkable anatomical behavioral
developmental
physiological and reproductive
similarities with primates
and also mhc expression with a few
exceptions
is very similar we see a high level of
conservation amino acid sequences and
immune system complexity
and that image that you see there on the
side is is demonstrating that with
respect to something very current to us
right now with cobin 19 susceptibility
that again is that conservation of amino
acid sequences those
bullet points that you see there on the
left are what lead to what you see on
the right so we have high cross
reactivity with many human directed
biologicals and primates there's of
course some exceptions to that
again like i just mentioned
susceptibility to viral infections
high between primates and humans in the
case of covet again we're seeing
acetogene and translated
protein sequences that are strongly
conserved across these
these primates and again you see that
more so in old world and attacks versus
for example marmosets and one of the
things that i find most exciting and i
wanted to really focus in this talk is
when we're working in our primate models
is we can have a clinical trial like
pre-clinical safety and efficacy study
so we can actually
parallel some of the really elaborate
therapies that we're thinking about for
patients and the outcome measures that
we're going to look at in patients
in our primates so you have this
essentially
pre-phase zero that you're doing in
monkeys
so how did how does this look at least
in
in what i was referencing earlier when
we think about immunology studies or
transplantation studies
you know primates are a very small
fraction of the animals that we use in
this research right so one third of one
percent and that's a really important to
to keep in mind but again they're uh
an incredibly important step when we
think about studies that have
meaningfully informed
how we walk into the human and how we
walk into the clinic and at least for
immunosuppressive drug development
primates have been almost exclusively
a gatekeeper in walking into clinical
transplantation for the last 40 years
so one of the things that is really kind
of interesting when you think about that
is not only the
the forward translation that's been
successful but as we start to think
about how
how we deal with things when they don't
go the way they think so you see this
nice figure of
of walking through the human through the
in vitro through the rodent into the
monkey
and then backwards again so
when we think about this idea of reverse
translation
we can really get into this idea of
how are our methods working how can we
do better and
i think clinical trials are a remarkable
way for us to really
take our cue from and think about how we
do better at this early phase so
clinical trials focus a lot on uniform
criteria
that inform inclusion and exclusion
shared sops across
trial sites statistical analysis plans
and agreements on clinically relevant
endpoints
another piece of a good clinical trials
design are really thinking about
strategies that reduce
design and post confounding so again
barriers to adherence for patients
and patient burden and finally reduced
variability to achieve higher power with
smaller numbers is always a
consideration
and certainly should be a consideration
when we're thinking about non-human
primates
so when we look at that clinical
experience and we think about it as a
target to reverse translate back into
our primate studies to
to improve them there are a couple of
factors that we know really affect rigor
in the clinical situation and this is
obviously very well studied and the
first being non-adherence
so when we see that there's not
adherence in the clinical patient we see
increased variance
lowering of study power and a reduction
in the magnitude of our treatment
effects
the second major factor is inappropriate
subjects to start so confounding our
safety and efficacy interpretation and
as we think about these factors and we
break them out into sort of treatment
patient and factors related to the
disease itself
on the treatment side pain and distress
associated with that so treatment
imposed restraints on the patient
limitations on sociality that the the
study might impose
or a big one is the frequency of medical
intervention so the frequency of that
treatment
leading to dropout or things like that
on the patient factor side the desire
for control
and preference it certainly plays a role
into adherence so control over one's
environment
control over one's uh again disease
course to some extent and how they how
they manage it
and then of course there's the factors
that just relate to the disease itself
so we know that our patients with
chronic disease report some of the
lowest quality of life measures
that actually result from the disease
states and one thing to keep in mind for
those of you that are using animal
models of disease these very highly
representative animal models of disease
have
significant welfare implications that we
need to keep
at the forefront of our minds so
one of the things that i like to keep in
mind is that what when we think about
our model design the more
intentional we are about it it's our
first and best defense it's study rigor
and animal welfare so again improving
our likelihood of benefit
improving likelihood of successful
translation and there are many things
that go into the state of our animals
that i wanted to summarize here we
talked about how sickness and disease so
the actual model itself certainly
factors in
a big one for those of us that are again
at that safety and efficacy
side of of use in in primates the
medical surgical interventions
themselves and post-substantial verdin
but also just being a research subject
of course so the handling in the
environment that we impose on our
research subjects
and this and the way that it affects
their sociality all of those factor into
their behavioral psychological and
physiological health
and one of the things that i think is
really key to keep in mind also in using
primates is their heterogeneity
is is really a strength of the model
right so
when we think about translational
strengths we don't want to we don't want
to drive that piece of it out
and certainly the ability to perform
interventions the way that we anticipate
with our clinical patients
is also a strength and again bringing
back in that
bringing that back to the forefront
really allows us to refine our methods
and think about how we can reduce that
burden
so as you think about that piece of
talking about what influenced
success or failure in the clinical trial
situation we can
we can connect that using behavioral
management there's certainly the disease
state factor so for example in the
situation that i described when we have
diabetic monkeys for example
you you are going to see that impose
inherent harms but we can certainly
address the aspects of what we consider
avoidable suffering
and that is allowing some determination
or preference
uh and thinking about motivation so
addressing more than just what the
animal needs but also their wants to
give an opportunity for them to
exercise choice and control particularly
over their environments
and to use a pre-randomization or
roll-in period to have our animals learn
study procedures in low-stress positive
reinforcement
conditions and this allows us to also
look at our animals ability to comply
and cope with the complicated treatment
regimen so as we talked about making
sure that that enrollment makes sense
that we're not enrolling what would
normally be considered an ineligible
uh animal and then the piece that is
also critical as you as you think also
of the caregivers
that that care for our animals day today
is this relationship building
so thinking about the frequency and
quality of the interactions
so that influences of course the
satisfaction and
the adherence of our animals with the
complexity of these treatment regimens
so the first aspect that we can sort of
have a look to when we think about
behavioral management
is the environment and supporting
sociality of our animals so
when we look at increasing environmental
complexity around our animals
and supporting sociality so supporting
successful pairings over
time and control and choice we're
looking at
having again environments that foster
species typical behavior that foster
interests and and again pair behaviors
or group behaviors
one of the things that we know is that
environments with very little stimuli i
can provoke sensitization to even the
smallest variations and that's been
demonstrated whether it's noise or scent
and this really has the potential to
affect animals in a very exaggerated way
we know it can over estimate
underestimate treatment effect
and i think there's also been similar
observations done nicely by
kelly metcalf pate when we talk about
sib modeling
where we start to see difference in
animals who who have different social
conditions imposed as well
so one of the things that i think is
also relevant
beyond just thinking about how does this
environment and their control over it
and how they experience it
influence again the the the scientific
outcome which i just
talked about but it also allows us to
have a an evaluation of welfare that's
very different from our typical ones
where we look at sort of
uh traditionally negative welfare
indicators right so we look at
things that again may be atypical for
the animals instead we're looking at in
this situation like this
play so it gives us a welfare assessment
that's looking for a positive balance in
our animals which is
is also an exciting and different way to
look at the animal experience
so one of the things that that we aim to
do here
was really look at the impact of our
most common
for most of us that are again looking at
safety and efficacy
that's typically sampling and dosing of
our animals and and that can be either
restraint based which we see
most commonly used whether that's
sedation or physical restraint
which has the potential for for stress
or chemical confounding of our outcome
measures
and it's quite uh quite a bit less
representative of what we'd anticipate
in the clinical situation where patients
are not experiencing restraint for these
types of common procedures
as compared with cooperative right so
that's less commonly used from what we
see when you look over the literature
it's still quite infrequent to see that
animals are working cooperatively
and this requires training for
cooperation but also has less potential
for confounding of
outcome measures and certainly is more
representative of the clinical patient
situation
and the reason that we were interested
in this of course is because the
physiological effects of restraint based
sampling
so one of the the major aspects of this
of course is
stress induction that's capable of
affecting a lot of these downstream
aspects of physiology including immune
status and
particularly for the the focus of most
non-human primate studies
uh being immunology based because of the
reasons that we talked about for model
selection of primates
this raises a high level of concern
chemical restraint of course
also has the potential to introduce
direct drug-related physiological
effects
so here what i wanted to talk about a
little bit is again the value of
positive reinforcement training so what
you're seeing here is
is one of our cinemagist macaques
presentation to one of our caregivers or
blood collection or drug administration
this is a practice session
and again what we're looking for here is
that roll-in period to do skills
training and qualification and they're
going to learn things like injections
oral dosing simple physical exams and
vitals
this is a way to collect urine on cue
of course blood collection dosing as you
see oral dosing in a reliable way
blood collection via heel stick or
vascular access port which we'll show in
a moment
and for those of us doing metabolic work
extended conscious metabolic testing or
fluid drug administration and hydration
assessments
this also allows us a way to manage
critical care for our animals
and why is this relevant because we
certainly see that it mitigates the
stress confounding
and and makes what we considered near
clinical enrollment
possible and what you can see down in
the corner there is you have this
this happens to be an intravenous
glucose tolerance test what we see is
the
the comparison between ketamine and
and that's in green versus animals who
are cooperating with the glucose
disappearance rate calculated between 10
and 30 minutes and what we see is not so
much that the use of ketamine
makes the curve abnormal but it
certainly depresses the glucose
disappearance rate
so that again you you introduce
inaccuracy
more than anything then then you can
look at the the curve with
with animals receiving ketamine and look
at that to be quite normal but you're
actually underestimating the the glucose
tolerance of that animal
one of the things that i like to point
out of course is that our training is
is very feasible for an investment for
most groups we average about three to
five hours in total training time for
our animals
with rhesus training out a little bit
sooner than our cinemagist macaques
and and i also just popped in here the
cit 07 which is the clinical eyelid
transplant
study that was that was done just pulled
out the inclusion criteria just to again
remind ourselves what we would expect in
the patient situation that patients are
able to comply with the procedures of
study protocol that they're involved
with intensive diabetes management
and so one of the things i think again
we remind ourselves
is that this improved adherence to the
study protocol
ultimately leads to to better data and
certainly from the perspective of
reduction of overall animal use we see a
reduction of dropouts
improvement of statistical power and
that of course increases our confidence
that we've answered these questions more
conclusively
so as we looked at our model influence
on research outcomes
and and did a retrospective study
looking at are animals that were
were under for example ketamine sedation
versus cooperatively trained
what we can see very clearly is that
even in a single event that
chemical restraint blunt serum cytokine
expression
and again when you're looking at the
immunology aspects of these animals and
trying to understand
outcomes from the immune perspective it
becomes very concerning when you see
for example in this case splinting of
multiple cytokines on a shared
physiological pathway
so you you see what is essentially a
general systemic effect on cytokine
expression
between cooperative and sedated animals
so this was something
that we found really interesting and
very
objective again in how chemical based
restraint was influencing our animals
and this again if you're interested in
looking in in more detail is in
scientific reports the link is there
in the same way understanding that again
this is not a just a sort of mandate to
say well we should we should
include both males and females because
it might have some
some influence on outcomes we see very
clearly between males and females that
there's a sexual dimorphism
in cytokine expression patterns that
really need to be addressed as you're
thinking about your study design so i
wanted to share that
as well as we think about how our design
of experiment influences our outcomes
so one of the things that we know and
and what you're seeing here is a racist
male
working under positive reinforcement
paradigm for uh vasco access port access
is that we we see some direct and
indirect
benefits that come from this of course
so direct on study is that
we we have the ability to obtain
physiologic data about the animal's
health that we could not otherwise
obtain right so these frequent serial
checks that happen
that are requiring some invasive or
reversive handling
couldn't be done in the same way if you
needed to use chemical or physical
restraints and require removal from
their peer group those sorts of things
so this really allows us to think very
differently about our experimental
design so it increases the support of
care that we can do for our animals
and it really enhances well being by
bringing them closer to the clinical
situation so we can do things like
rehydration
tpn and again as i said monitor with a
frequency
that that really allows us to intervene
early
and in a very effective way from the
welfare perspective
indirectly what we see is is the support
and coping with the research
environment so you you can't
evidently predict everything that's
going to happen on study
certainly and what what this allows us
to do is have a
a general positive cognitive bias that
we see from from animals towards
caregivers
so they associate these interactions
with caregivers as rewarding
and what we can assume from that is it
reduces the perception of pain of course
but also allows us to if we don't have
something that we anticipated
be able to do that with an animal who
was ready to cooperate
one of the next things we decided to
really look at having seen the cytokine
data and this is
work again by one of my students
got hunter opler that's uh having a look
at the impact of cooperation versus
chemical restraint during intensive
sampling
so what we would see in this situation
again of a typical
talk study for example and
what you see here is the timeline so
pre-sampling event for baseline health
physiologic assessment
day zero sampling and test article
administration
and then relatively frequent sampling
followed by less frequent regular
sampling for the duration of the study
and we had six animals in the in the
group that was chemically restrained
three males three females
and six animals in the cooperative group
so a total of 12
young adult monkeys and this is a 42-day
study
and what you can see aside from from
what i've already shown retrospectively
with the with the changes in immunology
is as we
as we look at sort of again standard
outcome measures that we would report in
a regulatory
situation is we see incidence of nausea
and abidine so again things like low
biscuit consumption
and vomiting were significantly greater
and animals sampled under chemical
restraint
compared to those who are sampled
cooperatively and this of course should
come as no surprise to anyone right when
you're using chemical restraint but i
think it's
it's quite important that we show that
this is
this is significantly different between
the two groups and that again it's
something that
you you need to be mindful of as you
think about how it could be improperly
attributed to the test article
so it is possible to increase our data
accuracy and reduce the variability that
we see by refining our model design
we've we've also
previously published our work when we
moved again from the
the use of intensive
chemical restraint and uh
in combination oftentimes with these
immunosuppression regimens and
transplant how you see
actual pathological changes for example
in the thymus which
which again you might expect again when
you're looking at immunosuppression
regimens
but you see that when you're working
with animals who have been cooperatively
trained
and that's the only difference again not
the test article change
you can see a completely normal thymus
and and again it's
it's incredibly important to really
understand the differences that result
simply from handling alone and and again
i like to show this and
and we've shown this before in drug
discovery today the comparison between
having a very minimal behavioral
management program where you see that
glycemic control in the top panel in a
versus the second row where you have
extended behavioral management and you
see the difference even in routine
glycemic control which is the primary
outcome measure of course for us
and as you look to panel b this is a
reflection of weight
between animals with behavioral
management and those
that don't have a full behavioral
management program and it's quite
striking how you see the difference
in weight loss or or essentially
having animals really thrive under this
regimen and again the difference being
behavioral management
and we really aim to show that this is
not related to our metabolic
intervention because
as you see in in panel c the
the insulin exposure of the animals is
very similar so it's not a deficit in
insulin
it's not a deficit in in glucose
disposal we see
again that there's relative little
difference between glucose disposal it's
improved of course
in the behavioral management group for
the reasons that we know as i showed
earlier
but again the real difference being the
the number of sedation events or number
of
restraint events these animals were
exposed to making a big difference in
primary outcomes on the study
so experimental designs can certainly be
influenced by many factors
and and we know that researchers safety
and infectious disease studies or
or thinking about the ease in which we
we sample are big factors in in how we
set this up
but certainly some of the the stress on
on research subjects related to these
decisions are important to think about
because we know that it can ultimately
confound study endpoints related to
immune response
and certainly safety two of which we
talked about as very
objective examples today that are very
critical in our ability to evaluate new
drugs or devices
behavioral management can foster
resilience in our animals and certainly
improves welfare
and i think it's important to always
acknowledge that translational failures
can happen despite our best
most rigorous science and in using
reverse translation or thinking about
how we
how we look at our clinical situation
and and what works
what doesn't work and thinking through
those refinements are really key to
enhancing our modeling
and of course deeply characterizing our
models avoids our misinterpretation of
study endpoints so no matter what our
study model design is
really understanding its influence on
these outcomes
supports our intentionality and how we
select our models and how we design our
experiments
and with that i want to acknowledge the
the great team that was doing this work
in particular i really want to call out
work that was done by
by our students and residents who
contributed to
to much of the new data that you see
here and
and of course the funding agencies that
supported this work in particular nih
and jdrf
thank you